[Music]
so lawyers for glenn maxwell
say this deserves a new trial after a
juror told media that he used his own
experience of being sexually abused
to persuade other jurors who doubted
witnesses oh oh that's what they did
yeah wait what can you say one more time
imagine i'm on a jury right yeah and
before you get selected for a jury
you're supposed to talk about if you
have conflict of interest with what's
going on yeah yeah so maybe they would
ask questions like have you ever
experienced sexual abuse and then you
would say no i'm chill and then you get
on the jury well this cat gets on the
jury and then after the trial he's like
hey you guys want to know how i swayed
the jury
i got sexually abused and i was telling
everybody hey
i got i went through this [ __ ] so you
better [ __ ] go with me on on getting
delaine guilty because and they felt
like bad because they're like i like
this juror guy we're friends now and he
made it personal he said that he shared
detailed experiences he says quote i
know what happened when i was sexually
abused i remember the color of the
carpet the walls some of it can be
replayed by like a video
um but i can't remember all the details
but there are some things that run
together that's like saying
no fair you got them to empathize with
what i did yeah bro what is this and so
she's all like yes why [ __ ] i was a
pedophile and yes i sexually trafficked
miners but that's not [ __ ] fair you
[ __ ] manipulated the jury so that's
so is the mistrial part the fact that he
told someone he did that or the fact
that he did it at all the fact that he
did it all right so do that well i guess
like he falsified his
uh qualification to be in the jury right
oh no no it's not about that you're
right you would be right but you're
thinking a little deeper than i think
what they want us to think right so
they're they're saying that
because he told the media he used his
experiences to sway the jurors he
tainted the jury pool because he wasn't
supposed to tell
he'd be neutral he was supposed to be
neutral and he wasn't supposed to be
using personal experience to to sway the
jury
so now that we're saying it's a mistrial
validity of the trial so there could be
mistrial she could
this could be over right and that's the
that's the actual thing that's going on
and i'm tired of using the word
conspiracy because it's not a conspiracy
and if it's a mistrial does that mean
they don't do they try her again or
she's just no it'll be double jeopardy
at that point
right oh wait you mean um if she could
be trialed for the same yeah because
it's a mystery oh they throw out the
case i think they don't have to do it
all over yeah wait would they do it over
i think if it's a mistrial you got yeah
do it all over this is a pretty crazy
like case so i would imagine that they
would have to do it again right or new
jury pool because i don't know these
legal rules right because i thought they
would just throw it out after a mistrial
the court may bring the individual back
to trial later or the prosecution may
choose to drop all charges if they drop
charges this means in the law's eyes the
trial never happened and the prosecution
never bought charges against the defense
oh that's what i thought so then they
just throw the case out right yeah so
when you go into the jury room they they
make someone a four person they
basically vote and go who's the leader
yeah yeah that person i can't i just
can't [ __ ] imagine
of course you're using personal [ __ ]
stories to sway the other people
especially that's what exactly that's
how it goes in the context of sexual
assault a lot of people give pushback
just because it's like a it's like the
empathy thing like they don't really
understand
like the nuance and it they they do a
lot of like victim blaming and [ __ ] you
know what i mean so like if someone is
giving their point of view or their
experience
is that so bad uh
it depends on the concept right so like
usually you're putting an objective like
clause in there in order to make it like
fair across like multiple boards so
imagine a different scenario where it's
like somebody's on trial um and then i'm
up for jury duty and i get selected but
i happen to be and the person is on
trial is maybe like a african-american
and i i'm secretly racist
right so then when i go in there i
choose to go in there because i'm hoping
to make my case and sway regardless of
the actual evidence in the case because
i feel a certain like way so that
technically is a mistrial or same thing
with like uh people who get lobbied for
like gun rights and stuff like that that
go into it right like maybe they have an
agenda that is um you know that they've
been lobbied to by by you know nra or
whatever in order to make sure our case
goes a certain way in those ones it's so
clear that's a mistrial that shouldn't
happen blah blah blah blah blah but in
this one it's technically within the
same clause but it's very different yeah
it's just the other side of the semester
because you would argue that personal
experience is very different than
personal interest would you say that's
the gray area
they could prove that this person was
like i was molested and guess what
revenge time [ __ ] they lied on the
prospective juror questionnaire deny
being the victim of sexual abuse so
that's perjury right oh so that's so
that's what it is that's the
technicality it gets [ __ ] up so yeah
so but wasn't this done purposefully
[ __ ] off right no yeah no dude cause you
could plant a jury remember contain the
jury this way you can you can purposely
set it up so that you taint a jury this
way and do we not believe that
pedophiles are in control of a lot of
[ __ ] right now because we saw what
happened to jeffrey epstein we see that
colleen maxwell gets convicted five or
six counts right including the worst one
which is trafficking a minor like right
as young as four some of the victims are
as young as 14 years old none of the
people in the black book are getting
prosecuted that's what blows my mind is
because during the trial they actually
released everybody in the black book you
connect there's a there's a independent
news
uh channel like they're on instagram and
all this stuff right um and they
released all the names on the black i
didn't have to be them why wasn't it cnn
why wasn't it fox because they're all
dirty damn right so why are they
protecting pedophiles it's the [ __ ]
weirdest thing we pull up the list for
people that don't know what is the
importance of the black so who do they
traffic the victims to who who wants to
[ __ ] kids right well the black book is
basically a ledger of all the people who
came to the island who flew on the plane
like
they they kept great records and then
they wrote in all the people it's the
same [ __ ] as like a [ __ ] uh general
ledger for a tax audit no of course yeah
so it's basically that's what the black
book is it's a guest list or anyone
that's been on his plane why is the
media protecting these people why why
why isn't the media blasting out who the
names are like i mean this is one of the
craziest cases in history and for the
most part not a lot of people are
covering this case except for very like
in the middle about the night that she
was convicted five or six counts the two
prison guards who fell asleep or
whatever were distracted when jeffrey
epstein quote unquote killed himself
which we all don't think happened
um they all got the charges dropped
nobody cares
it's almost like there's a quid pro quo
hey you shut the [ __ ] up for a certain
amount of time when there's the height
of all this stuff will make it all
disappear and that's what's happening
and thank goodness we're a legitimate
news channel a joke lose news channel
and no one takes us [ __ ] seriously so
we could talk about it and they'll be
like oh no one's gonna listen to them
they're too crazy but we can actually
openly talk about it do you think they
can [ __ ] talk about this [ __ ] on cnn
[ __ ] no wish they had a special court
case circumstance because knowing how
sophisticated the organization is right
it's so easy to plan a juror it's so
easy to have the judge in their pocket
or the prosecutor they need to like have
some sort of like third party or like
you know how like cops they have like
internal affairs or there's just like a
different
uh like auditing
group that can come in and specially
treat this circumstance like a neutral
third party yeah like playing by normal
criminal rules when you know that their
reach has already infiltrated the whole
thing like it's just
of course nothing's going to come out of
it yeah high profile case with like
leaders of america in the uk let's do
the case in the u.s because my expected
my what i expect is what's happening
this whole thing to just get brushed
under the rug and thrown away that's
really going on your way to create that
mistrial because when you're a juror you
don't have to tell anybody
why you came to that decision yeah why
would they go on media and [ __ ] and
they tell you the whole [ __ ] time
don't talk about the case you can't talk
about for this long especially how high
profile this is you're not even supposed
to know who the [ __ ] jerk why is it
high profile you're talking about it's a
high profile case because all these high
profile people wanted to [ __ ] on kids
yeah that's what's crazy about it and it
seems like they're protected and also
too the the charges that are being filed
against galen is only from like the
early years of epstein and it's not even
the later stuff where the actual real
juicy stuff where he has hot ties with
like higher government officials like
they're not even going into that because
there is a conflict of interest there
and the judge ordered all of it sealed
yeah the judge ordered all of it sealed
because he thought it'd be indecent to
reveal all this to the public because
it's just like it's like it's like pg-13
rated r yeah so it just was like i'm
just trying to protect you guys from
this gross [ __ ]
it's like nah we're all [ __ ]
meanwhile during the oj trial
oj has to try the gloves on and then
like how many times he stabbed nicole
over and over and over and over and over
again like on live television you could
find pictures of the murder scene of oj
on google images that's not indecent but
yeah like what is it give me a break bro
ridiculous it's insane because they
don't want the public to actually make a
little street view
they don't want the public to make a
decision is what it is so like you keep
it under the rug uh and then they go oh
anyone questioning it that's just a
conspiracy theorist you know they're
like oh those are rogan fans that are
saying epstein didn't kill himself right
they used cnn recently to try to uh
make rogan seem like a crazy guy that
takes uh horse pill
horse pill medicine or whatever right
they're trying to d
basically de-credit big credit yeah yeah
his uh uh like he's yeah he's they try
to discredit his
thinking period so i'm like
this is gonna happen like
if you go down the list of people who
are questioning stuff yeah you know what
i'm mad about is is they never even give
us hush money i mean like if they
offered jk news to get like hey man
here's here's some money to shut the
[ __ ] up i would have been like yes i
play the game finally i'm like it'd be
like cnn too but they never offered so
[ __ ] it dude i'm gonna go for it we'll
get loud so you have to pay attachment
that's it that's all we're trying to do
here
but no one actually cares and gives a
[ __ ] anyway that's the crazy part
yeah it's wild man because i want to go
go down the list and see like um them
being investigated anyway we'll go to
the next article it's about uh fifi bags
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you